You won't survive for long out there.
There's room for you in our group
if you want.
She's just another mouth to feed.
If we leave her out here, she'll die.
I mean, that question.
Your sense of mercy, David.
Maybe that's God's will.
Let me protect you.
The others want to kill you.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie.
This will be my last of us
Episode 8 Trailer Video.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs and
references, so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes
and careful spoilers from episode seven
if you haven't seen it yet.
The title of the episode is
When We Are In Need,
which is a reference to Ellie's fight
with David's group.
Here, David's
the main antagonist here in the prayer
that they have written on their banner
when we are in need.
He shall provide later
who treats Ellie as if she's sent by God
to answer their prayers for food.
Because there's this whole bad
vibe to the trailer and that's on purpose.
David's group are affectionately referred
to by the fans
as the Cannibals,
and there's a huge Troy Baker cameo here.
He's playing James and secondary
antagonist, part of David's group.
And even though it seems like he's
the bad guy, he wants to kill Ellie,
like he pulls his gun up on her
a couple of times,
you find out that he's actually one of
the more merciful ones of the bunch.
It seems like
we're going to get a much bigger flashback
when they're a group to show how
they became what they are in present day.
Some of these scenes might be happening
in present day, though,
but they're meant to be a group of minor
antagonists for Ellie
and Joel
later in the events of the first game,
and they're meant to be part
of the same group
that they ran into at the University,
the same one that Joel killed.
He was from David's group.
Remember, they haven't traveled very far.
She just drug him to a house nearby.
So they're still in that area
around the university
when she runs into David's group here.
This is all right
out of the game with a bunch of stuff
added in like they've done
with previous episodes before. Like, you
get more backstory and all the characters
just to flesh everyone out.
Hello.
We just want to talk any sudden moves.
And I put one right between your eyes.
Ditto for Buddy Boy over there.
What do you want?
Names, David.
This here's my friend James
from a larger group.
Women.
Children are all very, very hungry.
So am I.
Women and children
are all very hungry, too.
Well,
maybe we could trade you
for some of that meat there.
What do you need?
And weapons, ammo, clothes, medicine.
In a lot of the episodes, Ellie,
by herself
trying to deal with this other group
while she still continues to nurse Joel
back to hell.
Like at the beginning of the trailer,
you see the aftermath of episode six
where she slowly nurses him
back to consciousness.
She managed to find some string
and close his wound,
but he's still on the edge of death,
like he's still barely there.
You see her hunting for the stag
to try and find them some food,
showing off some of the skills
that she's learned, some survival skills.
She's not completely there yet, but she's
gotten better at surviving on her own.
This is all right out of the games.
This won't last very long.
So in the game, this is basically
when she runs into David's people.
She runs into David and James.
Oh, hey there.
Surprise, surprise. Looking for some food.
Are you in the vibe
you get from David and James in
the trailer
is very similar to the vibe in the games
where they present themselves
as very benevolent people.
Like, Oh, hey, it's another mouth to feed,
so great, why don't we help each other
when really they have much
more sinister plans for her?
And suddenly you realize the scene of them
looking with the banner above them
in this meeting room here in this lodge,
when we are in need, he shall provide.
Is them treating Ellie
like she's a nice snack sent
by God because it's winter
and they've run out of food.
And like I said, even though
they're treating the Troy Baker character
like he's
one of the worst ones trying to kill
Ellie, he's actually meant to be the nicer
of the two of them, of him in David,
because he wants to do this quickly.
James tells David
that she's another mouth to feed.
They can't even think of keeping her
around.
Maybe God wants her to die.
Maybe that's his will.
It is not feasible
keeping another person around.
But David argues with him
that they should like.
He's trying to make it seem like he's
trying to help this person.
And here's where the other shoe drops.
Because in the games around this time,
there are infected in this area.
But remember, Joel said a long time ago
that the biggest thing
they had to worry about in
these remote areas were other people.
The whole idea is that other people
are even more dangerous than the fungus.
There are infected in this area where
they are because it's somewhat populated.
There's a small group of people like
David's group is a small group of people.
So it's not like it's
completely free of the fungus,
but it's not nearly as bad as it is in the
quarantine zone in more populated areas.
That's where you tend
to find more of the fungus
just because it feeds on other people.
That's its food source, basically.
And just like Joel told her, no, we can't
have a fire because the people out
there are raters that look to kill us
and do even worse things to us.
In the even worse part is where
we get to David's group in the trailers.
It seems like David tries to help her
like, Oh, he's the nice guy I like.
He's trying to protect her. Nope.
He basically wants to trap Ellie
and keep her as his own personal plaything
in the most sadistic way.
So now all the other members of his group
that might want to eat her,
which is bad enough on its own, somehow
seem like the better option of the two.
Troy Baker
not coming off as bad in these trailers.
Just kill her and be done with it.
Don't play with your food.
There's lots of moments in the games
in this trailer, just a few changes.
They've expanded the scene
with Davis Group
just to flesh out their characters,
their groups, backstory a little more.
Her hunting the deer at the beginning
here is right out of the games.
But in the episode, she's using Joel's
rifle instead of the boat from the games.
As you can see, that's basically how
she winds up running into David's group.
And they slowly begin to find out, like
Davis starts to figure out who she is.
Wait a minute. I've been
slaughtered by a
crazy man.
And get that crazy man
traveling a little girl.
There were a couple of our people
that came running back and said they ran
into a crazy old man in a little girl
that was with him, and some of them died.
So it's a very suspenseful episode,
like a very crazy episode
compared to last week.
If you didn't think
there was enough action in episode seven,
this is completely the opposite of that.
It's like wall to wall action.
It starts out with Ellie
trying to save Joel.
Hunting this deer
like big test for her in survival skills,
and then running into David's group
and trying to deal with them on her own.
Mind you, later in the trailer, you see
the lodge where they were meeting on fire.
This seems like Ellie
trying to make her escape.
And Joel basically has to force himself
to stay conscious long enough
to try and save her in his condition
after she's been captured by David.
So does wind up being a big rally
for Joel's character, too.
The way they played this, they kind of
did this in previous episodes as well,
where they move through the plot
really fast because in the games
it was a much bigger time jump
between when Joel was wounded
at the university by David's group
and when Ellie first encounters
David in the wild here with James.
And remember,
there's only one more episode after this,
and they're supposed to cover the entire
first game during season one,
which is why they're moving
through the plot so fast.
It kind of feels like they needed
ten episodes instead of just nine.
So that means that the finale
is going to have to be super sized
because there's still so much stuff
that happens during the first game.
We can wait to talk about that until they
drop the trailer for episode nine.
Remember episode nine is the finale.
They're still on the mission
to find the fireflies.
This has just been a detour
to Nurse Joel back to health
so that doesn't die on her.
But they decided to try and make it
to Salt Lake City, Utah,
where the Fireflies had indicated
that they'd retreated to on that
map, which is still a pretty solid journey
from them.
They haven't gone that far.
Remember, Ellie,
just drug them to a nearby house
in this suburb near the university.
It wasn't that far.
So they're still in the nearby area
where they were in episode six.
That's why you see David's group
patrolling in and around these same houses
where Ellie has been hiding with Joel.
It seems like they're trying to say
in the trailer
that David is like
the pastor of their group, which just adds
this level of sinister
and evil to his character.
Oh, the holy man.
He wouldn't be the evil person.
He wants to protect this young child,
not keep her like a pet.
No one who speaks German
could be an evil man.
This scene of David talking to her, saying
the others want to kill you,
I want to keep you alive.
Is him talking to her
after he's trapped her behind these bars?
Also right out of the games.
They might have changed the dialog
just a little bit.
They did that with Riley's conversation
at the end of episode seven.
But it's the same basic scene,
just like the scenes in episode
seven and previous episodes.
Overall, the episodes have adapted
the plot of the games pretty closely.
Like a lot of the scenes in the dialog
are taken directly from the games
they've just expanded on. Some of that.
Like Episode three is a good example
where they just add
a whole bunch of backstory for characters
that you only get
a little bit from in the games.
For those of you asking about season
two and beyond, they've actually said that
they're planning on splitting the events
of the second game for future seasons.
So like Season two
won't be all of the second game.
It'll be like
the first half of the second game,
maybe even less than that
if you haven't played the games.
The second game is almost like twice
as long as the first game.
There's just so much more stuff
going on in that.
And this is also assuming they eventually
make the last of Us 3 game,
which Neil Druckmann has talked about in
the past, is their Last of Us.
Part three They'll just say, Right now
our focus is on we have
we have the multiplayer game coming out
and we're
going to reveal more of that later
this year.
Beyond that, it's
the same process we've always had.
We don't
we don't do something
that we're not extremely passionate about.
So unless we had a really good,
compelling story to keep the story going,
then we it ends up part two.
The way he talks about
is very noncommittal.
Like, well,
if we find a good story, we'll do it.
But clearly they probably plan on doing it
just because the first two games
were so successful, even though fans
weren't quite as hot on the second game.
Mostly stuff like that comes down to money
and they're supposedly
making The Last of Us
multiplayer game right now,
and that's going to be extra material
that wasn't featured
in the first two games.
Like it'll be a new story
with other characters.
We'll see the incorporating of that stuff
in the future seasons as well.
But if you spotted any of Easter eggs
or references in the trailer
that it didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments
in my full Episode eight video we'll post
next Sunday after they release it.
The other real big reminder
is The Mandalorian Season
three episodes are starting
and I'm doing videos for all the episodes
just like I did for previous seasons.
More Pedro Pascal, Pedro
Pascal into the Pascal verse.
Those episodes release at midnight
Tuesday nights Pacific Time.
My episode videos will post later
in the mornings on Wednesdays.
They just released the opening scene from
The Mandalorian Season 3 Episode 1.
You can click here for my video from that
and click here for My Full Last of Us
Episode 7 Video and Easter Eggs.